say hello everyone hi dick you see
alright before we go what with the way
where my hat here look it looks like
Ernest the way it looks like a like a
half hat and now I have helmet hair but
it's just a head alright this is a
horrible starts this video hey we just
wanted to let you guys know that we're
gonna be gone for a couple weeks here on
not really on vacation migrating some
stuff over and there have been a ton of
videos right now that have been deemed
too controversial for YouTube now we
don't know exactly because they haven't
emailed us back but as far as we know it
these would be the videos that could be
even considered borderline so those of
you who have not joined up at mug Club
lot of credit calm slash mug Club we've
added all of these videos to the blaze
back catalog so what is it is it quarter
black with like 40 videos more than that
okay okay it's over 50 videos that will
no longer be available on YouTube
including some of our classics I think
we'll have a overlay here so if you want
to see these
you're not going able to find them on
youtube we're trying to play ball we'll
see what happens hopefully they answer
that the half-asian kraken and if not
just join up at mug club and go watch
them over at the blaze more more footage
than you could watch this entire fourth
of July break look he's trying to hide
his face like you don't know this is a
person there